les résultats des recherches sont
préliminaires mais il confirme le pire
les dépouilles de 215 enfants
autochtones arrachés à leurs familles
est confiée à l'école résidentiel de
kamloops et ont trouvé la mort pour la
communauté des caps negues avoisinantes
la douleur est immense choc selon la
communauté autochtone ces décès
n'avaient jamais été répertorié active
de 1897 1969 les codes résidentiel de
kamloops était une des plus gros sur
pays et pouvait accueillir 500
pensionnaires des enfants autochtones de
partout en colombie britannique mais
aussi d'ailleurs au pays
il était envoyé à l'union des chefs
autochtones de la colombie britannique
veut aller au fond des choses
son chef réclame une enquête approfondie
pour identifier les 215 enfants de masse
à ottawa la chambre des communes a
observé une minute de silence
l'ondé de choc provoquée par la
découverte s'est faite sentir d'un bout
à l'autre du pays comme blanches géants
comme maire j'ai mal j'ai physiquement
mal écoles résidentielles de kamloops
était loin d'être unique au canada
des dépouilles de centaines d'autres
enfants pourraient être découverts
ailleurs au pays reconnaît le
gouvernement fédéral ça demeure une
honte nationale
ce qui est encore plus en te sais qu'il
ya beaucoup de gens qui savent pas cette
réalité 2 81 10 % de la population à
kamloops comme ailleurs au pays cette
terrible découverte prouve une blessure
qui n'a jamais complètement guérie chez
les membres des premières nations de
centre national pour la vérité et la
réconciliation estime qu'au moins quatre
mille cent enfants sont morts au pays
dans les écoles résidentielles et les
pensionnats autochtones ici mathieu gaye
i radio canada kamloops